Jim Cantore he's a certified broadcast
meteorologist not like some of those
other guys who aren't certified also
been with the Weather Channel for I
think over 30 years now
and he's more than just biceps he is
he's a man of integrity and he joins us
now from Wrightsville Beach North
Carolina hi Jim
good morning mr. Patrick how are you sir
I'm doing okay but how about you very
good I'm a little worn out yeah so you
know that the pregame sometimes is uh
get you worn out than the adrenaline
kind of gets you through it so I'm going
for that to kick in and that should be
about tonight and this thing starts
hammer away when is it gonna get bad and
how bad will it get guard it's already
bad in the Outer Banks the other banks
getting getting wind they're getting uh
you know big waves they're coming in the
beach erosion started up there so that's
gonna prickle down here in Southeast
North Carolina that eventually down the
South Carolina coast the problem of this
one Danny is we got like 36 48 hours of
you know big wind just heavy rain stuff
when you get these big big ones out
there they stall or in a stall right
where we are and just dump phenomenal
amount of rain and that's what we got
with this month farts and so the
category is category downgraded to a
three no it's too so but here's the deal
people people focus on that category and
what they don't realize is it's still
gonna put the st. whether this was a
three or four or two it's still gonna
produce the same muttering all right
it's about the speed of the movement
that produces the rain plus the size of
this thing and you have 400 mile wide
tropical storm Winfield so it's going to
be pushing all that water into the Outer
Banks in Southeast Virginia in South
Carolina and time as it moves south so
you just beat up those beaches over
several high tide cycles so the storm
surge potential and the rainfall
potential have not changed regardless of
the category now what tells you I will
say this what's going to help us out a
little bit is that downgrade isn't gonna
give us as much wind damage potential
structural damage pitching from the wind
but now don't be fooled you really go 30
40 hours with that kind of wind cranking
up gonna be a lot of trees a lot of
power lines coming down and a lot of
flooding
when's the last time you were scare
you know it's it scared is probably now
I mean when the surge came up in Katrina
about 25 to 30 feet that kind of
freaking out a little bit is I wasn't
expecting it so when I'm not really I
expect myself to know what's gonna
happen but when it when something kind
of catches me off guard because we we
didn't know all that water was gonna
come in so quickly and that's what
catches people off guard that's why you
know fifty percent of the deaths in
tropical systems are because of the
storm surge because the water comes up
so quickly catches people off guard you
can't get out of it can't get out of it
so that that kind of freaked us out a
little bit and we had to you know
scramble we had to get our gear inside
as much as we can a lot of the guys were
so exhausted with their gear in their
car their cars are out there floating in
a parking lot like a rubber ducky
we're getting all the vets the heroes
that the Armed Forces retirement on the
Gulf War up on the second floor
everybody was down there eating all the
medications were down there power goes
out and you're trying to carry you know
these guys that are in these battery
powered wheelchairs up those you know
now humid soaked slippery stairs because
the power's out so it was just a
horrible situation that was a bad day
that's a really bad day
what's the difference in hurricanes we
know the grades there but are there are
there different hurricanes I mean you
have I think the biggest thing is the
size that's why you know we get kind of
hung up on these categories you know an
interesting one up this is what we did
on the same date back in 2008 when
hurricane I came into Galveston that
wasn't a - like this one is but it
produced cat four waves and surge so
that's why so many people died that's
why it completely completely gutted the
Bolivar Peninsula because people focused
on it no it's only a - I'm gonna stay
that's only it - that's not it
you've got to look at the size you got
to look at the wind field around this
thing and you got to realize this thing
is pushing so much water toward the
coastline and once you push it up a
river or push it onto the coast it has
no play nothing to do but pile up and
that's what it's gonna do Jim Cantore
from The Weather Channel joining us from
North Carolina the biceps on display
yesterday we
proudly showed all of your it felt like
you were posing a little bit like an NFL
referee would you like to defend what
you were doing yesterday and you're very
very tight-fitted golf shirt yeah I
can't help it they gave me a woman's law
[Laughter]
was picking on my back right I take a
lot of pride in the back Paulie
were you pointing out his traps didn't
look like that they were worked I'm just
saying body builders like mr. Cantore
they feature certain things like the
traps and you know the lats don't show
as well on TV Jim yeah yeah blue is kind
of a you know it's one of those colors
doesn't doesn't really define a lot of
things officer maybe I'll good maybe
I'll gently different bright orange or
some wine and green next time well maybe
that'll show up a little bit better are
there I thought that was a pretty funny
guys to be honest that I needed a little
levity frankly are there Weather Channel
to help ease oh my gosh it's crazy bro
it's crazy I mean if you you know yeah
when you when you're on TV people kind
of develop a relationship with you
because they see you where they they
hear you every day you know you win -
they're at their living room or or you
know they're listening device however
they hear or watch you so they kind of
develop this relationship with you
I just never my wildest dreams ever
thought you know a weather guy would we
would approach that that type of level
but well wait so what do you want to
come out and take pictures with it's
nice it's very nice very free pretty
nice yeah but you're not just a regular
Weather Channel guy you're not a guy in
a suit and tie telling us you know the
five-day forecast like you're you're a
man no this is when we come out here to
do this these kind of things this is our
Super Bowl so you know we get amped up
for it we wanted we want to bring people
into the weather look show what's going
on you know the adrenaline starts
pumping so it really is it's our game
day well we have events like this so if
that's what we're doing that and viewers
are absorbing that and enjoying it and
bracing it so be it
we're here's the here the one thing I
love is the fact that when people is
this thing that follows me around now
hey if Dan Torre shows up
hell's gonna break loose yeah if that's
how you feel and you and you leave and
evacuate if that's what emergency
officials are telling you to do great
it should accomplish I'll take it yeah
but I would want to stay to see Jim
Cantore when he came to town I'd be one
of those groupies though yeah till the
water starts to rise you know all of a
sudden your cars don't know what then
you may want to leave you know if you
want to on your next live shot on the
Weather Channel maybe show off your back
muscles the lats we'd be more than happy
to display that you know I'll promote it
if we didn't have a serious
life-or-death situation on our hands you
know talk to me in the winter well we'll
have some fun in the winter because
usually people you know those are a lot
more fun you know push-ups in the snow
for you oh I love that I love that last
year where you're off the side of the
road I think your feet were up on the
guardrail we're showing it right now for
you great stuff as always be safe Jim we
appreciate your time thanks buddy
I call Jim Cantore and whether Jim yeah
their shoulder right now kid Tori's up
in Millberry mass 50 inches of snow it's
just great he's covering his beard is
covered with ice and he's just pumping
out push-ups he's so great its toes up
yeah pump it up push-ups while giving
the up still expecting heavy volume here
man coming down from Nova Scotia three
four five six big good sport it's the
best yeah and I get it you know that
this is very serious with what's going
on but you know we just try to provide a
little levity for him while he's dealing
with something this serious nature for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
you